the Trump administration is considering
stimulus aid for oil and gas producers
as oil prices plummets Wisconsin's
Republican leaders are suing over the
Democratic Governors lockdown order
people stuck at home worldwide have been
a boon for Netflix adding nearly 16
million new subscribers hi I'm Jason
Bellini with the latest reporting on the
coronavirus crisis from The Wall Street
Journal the energy business is very
important to us as oil prices have
collapsed the Trump administration is
weighing stimulus aid for oil and gas
companies people familiar with the
matter tell the journal the aid would
come in exchange for government
ownership stakes in companies or their
crude reserves this plan is one of
several options on the table and faces
long odds given Democrats will likely
oppose using stimulus funds to help the
oil industry separately the president
also said he would support a four
hundred and eighty four billion dollar
aid package for small businesses and
hospitals it's moving to the house after
the Senate passed to Tuesday night
Republican lawmakers in Wisconsin filed
an injunction targeting governor Tony
Evers order for businesses to close and
Wisconsin Isis to stay home through May
26 it's the latest in a growing debate
around efforts to slow the spread of the
virus while not constricting the economy
Republican leaders argue they weren't
consulted about the decision and that
restrictions should be eased in rural
counties where there are few cases the
governor's administration says the order
has slowed the spread of the infection
and prevented deaths
meanwhile Attorney General William Barr
said the Department of Justice would
consider supporting those who ledge
their rights have been violated by these
strict lockdown measures Netflix scored
16 million new subscribers in the first
quarter of 2020 that's more than double
what the company had forecast but the
streaming giant said the breakneck pace
of growth was unlikely to continue its
stock is up 34 percent year-to-date
making the company one of the few to see
shares appreciate during the coronavirus
Christ
as people stuck at home around the globe
or turning to streaming services for
entertainment
most of the growth is from outside of
North America
Netflix has a challenge ahead of it
practically all of its content
production has ground to a halt due to
the pandemic